elections what you need to know so you
can cast your vote don't forget rochford
District Council and some parish
elections take place on the fifth of may
2011 on the same day there will also be
a uk-wide referendum on changing the
voting system for electing MPs to the UK
Parliament one third of the district
council is up for reelection as well as
the following parish councils ashington
darling magma canoodle foul ness island
great wakering hawk well pagal shown
Stanbridge sutter if you're unable to go
to the polling station on Election Day
you can apply for a postal or proxy vote
the closing date for new postal votes or
changes to existing postal or proxy
arrangements for these elections is 5
p.m. on the fourteenth of April the
closing date for new proxy voting
applications is 5 p.m. on the twenty
first of April application forms can be
downloaded from the council's website
WWE govt UK or you can contact the
election office helpline by telephone on
0 1 702 318 187 district wards involved
in this year's elections are ashington
and canoe 'don darling and sutton foul
nests and great wakering hawk world
north hawk well south Hawk well west
hockley central hullbridge down hall and
raw earth grained lodge Swain park
rochford registering to vote it gives
you a chance to elect your local council
representatives and have your say about
how your district is rung voting is your
opportunity to make a difference to the
issues that are important to you and the
community there's lots more information
on the elections and how to vote on the
website just visit w WH for Garvey UK
/in
actions to find out the current
composition of Rochford District Council
how you can register to vote application
forms for proxy and postal voting past
election results and on election night
the website will be updated with all the
results from the local elections
welfare reforms from April in June's
emergency budget the coalitional
government announced a series of welfare
reforms including changes to the housing
and council tax benefit schemes the
first of these changes comes into effect
on the first of april 2011 and will
affect customers in receipt of local
housing allowance known as LH pay or who
have a non dependent living with them
changing to LH a currently customers in
receipt of this have their benefits set
in line with the average rent for a
suitably sized property in the area this
means that the rent of five out of ten
properties should be at or below this
level from April first this will change
the LH a rate will be reduced so that
only the lowest three out of ten
properties will be at or below this rate
for people already getting benefit this
change will apply nine months after the
anniversary of their claim for example
if someone applied in November 2010 the
new rate will apply from August 2012
however if they move or the number of
occupiers in their property changes the
new rate will apply from when the change
occurs for its customers who make a new
claim the new rules will apply
straightaway we don't know the exact
rates that will apply from April the
rates are published every month on our
website and can be found at ww our govt
UK /l h a rates other changes that will
apply from April in some instances
customers can receive up to 15 pounds
per week more than their rent this will
stop from April for new claims payments
to customers who already receive this
will stop on the anniversary of their
claim there will be a restriction placed
on the maximum size property for which
benefit can be paid the maximum LH a
rate will be that for a 4-bedroom
property the rules governing when we can
pay benefit directly to a landlord will
change at the moment we can only do this
when someone is considered vulnerable
unable to manage their finances or are
eight weeks or more in arrears from
April we will also be
to pay a landlord if this will help to
retain or secure a tenancy we will be
able to take into account the needs is
someone who has an extra bedroom because
they have a carer stay with them
overnight changes to non-dependent
deductions a non dependent is someone
who lives with a claimant but is not
their partner or dependent child
commonly they are adult children or
parents they are expected to contribute
towards the rent and council tax and
when calculating someone's entitlement
to benefit a deduction is often made the
exact amount depends upon the non
dependents own financial circumstances
since 2001 these deductions have been
frozen the government has announced they
intend to return these to the level they
would have been if they had not been
frozen by 2014 starting from april 2011
these deductions will again start to
rise
the council's revenues and benefits team
has become one of only a small number of
local government departments in the east
of england to have received and
nationally recognized accreditation for
its excellent customer service the team
which is responsible for administrate
administering housing and council tax
benefits to residents as well as
collecting council tax business rates
and investigating benefit fraud has been
killed one of only three revenues and
benefits departments in East Anglia to
have received customer service
excellence accreditation the
government's customs service standard in
order to receive the accreditation
Rochford's revenues and benefits team
had to demonstrate to an Assessor that
they are committed to making sure
customers who use their services are
provided with the information they need
quickly professionally and courteously
the assessment also had to show evidence
that the team was continuously striving
to improve and develop the service in
response to the needs of its customers
rochford is one of only 25 revenues and
benefits departments nationally to have
earned the accreditation and the first
department within rot for District
Council to all have achieved this status
out and about in the area commuting
village day on junior 11th between 11am
and 5 p.m. enjoy a day out in commuting
with plenty for everyone to enjoy a
church will be open with tower tours
there'll be a tug of war bouncy castle
dog show and various other shows on the
village green they'll also be an
opportunity to travel to the wetlands at
wallasey the memorial hall will be open
for ploughman's lunches and in the
grounds there'll be a vintage tractor
and steam engine display you can also
enjoy the school fete on the same day
hot leighton hawk well wi will hold us
in your jizz day coffee morning on april
the 23rd between 10am and 12 noon at the
old fire station hotly and the cost is
one pound for tea or coffee and cake if
you'd like to view the wonderful
wildlife of foul ness here's your chance
willett or a foul ness island it's on
may the eighteenth or may the 25th from
630pm and you'll need to book early to
avoid disappointment to have a guided
tour of this fascinating part of our
district there are limited places
available the cost is 16 pounds per
person and you need to contact julia
mitchell or julie chelmsford on 0 1 702
3181 double for the rockford district
easter holiday activity program will be
held at various locations across the
district between april the 11th and 21st
there will be arts and sports activities
for all ages up to 16 across the
rockford district including an Easter
Sunday go to www govt UK forward slash
holiday activities for full details or
you can contact 0170 25 463 double six
and wild woods day another date for your
diary the rockford districts big day out
is gearing up for its eighth year the
council's layer team is currently
organizing the annual wild woods day in
hockley woods on saturday june the
fourth from 11am to 4pm the popular free
family fun day will see the return of
past favorites as well as new activities
keep checking www Rochford gavotte UK
forward slash for more details
raley windmill will reopen again on
April a second through to and including
sep tember the opening times are
wednesdays from ten a.m. to 1pm and
saturdays and sundays from 1pm to 4pm
the following exhibitionist will take
place on the second floor of a windmill
during the 2011 season please also note
later on when the dates will be for the
windmill closing for private events
entry is free but donations are welcome
so we start with rayleigh through the
looking glass between 8th with a second
and maybe 11th this local historical
group will be anticipating their huge
collection historical artifacts and
documents sales in the wind may the 14th
the jeweler 19th an exhibition that was
created as part of the year-long
celebration of the windmills 200th
anniversary max doling between june the
22nd in july the 24th max is a local
artist who uses Manos screen prints on
vinyl for display on windows to create
unique effects using natural daylight
but journey to the podium july the 27th
to august the 21st this exhibition
appears artists with essex athletes who
have the potential to compete in the
London 2012 games artwork has been
created to celebrate the athletes
achievements the journey to the podium
project has been awarded the inspire
mark which recognises projects uniquely
inspired by the olympic and paralympic
values sandra ray between august the
24th and September the 28th Sandra is a
Brazilian born artist now living in
Essex she draws her inspiration from
life with the past being a constant
influence in her work she has drawn to
art that his abstract which is reflected
in her own style of painting and the
private events that are happening in the
windmill which mean they will be closing
April the ninth may the 21st June the
4th july the second and sep tember the
24th please check before visiting as
these dates are subject to change and a
missions for more information we'll
contact the council's leisure team on 0
1 702 546 366 or email later at watch
the gulf dr k